let's talk more about the sessions
retirement really firing with South
Carolina Republican congressman trey
Gowdy who sits on the Judiciary
intelligence committees and chairs the
Oversight and Government Reform
Committee congressman thanks for being
here yes sir
your thoughts of this news it was gonna
happen I knew it was gonna happen after
the election I did not think it would
happen before all the votes had been
counted but he's been a proverbial dead
man walking for several months now
breath yeah you know Chuck Schumer had a
real problem with the acting Attorney
General take a listen our paramount view
is that any Attorney General whether
this one or another one should not be
able to interfere with the mulher
investigation in any way they should not
be able to end it they should not be
able to limit it they should not be able
to interfere with Muller going forward
and doing what he thinks is the right
thing and that will help guide us as we
go through this process so their concern
is that Matt Whitaker is going to do
that is that your concern no Brett every
prosecutor has jurisdictional boundaries
I don't know a single prosecutor that
does not and Muller cr6 No Boundaries
were set by rod Rosen sign in the memo
that you have seen and they were altered
amended in the memo that we have not
seen but there's never been a prosecutor
that just had unfettered power to go
investigate whatever the heck he or she
wanted to do if you're a state
prosecutor you can't investigate federal
crimes if you're in New York you can't
investigate things in Idaho so the
notion that we're going to create a
special counsel that has no boss no
jurisdictional strictures at all it's
just typical Chuck Schumer and I think
it's why so few people take him
seriously what about the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rhodes Rosen Stein and his
role here one would have assumed that
the deputy that's why he's a deputy if
the Attorney General is not there would
step in as acting you would these are
interesting times that we rent rod
Rosenstein
I was ready to question him at 37 pages
worth of questions for him Brett a
couple of weeks ago of course he is
alleged to have wanted to vote the 25th
amendment and questioning the
president's fitness for office so I'm
not sure that would have been the right
pick but he is overseeing the Muller
probe right now I don't think anything's
gonna happen to rod until after Muller
finishes his investigation and then what
happens after that'll be between the
president rod Rosa Stein had a meeting
today at the White House schedules will
be there tomorrow do you have any sense
when Muller moves forward with anything
do you have any timeline I I don't and
I'd be really disappointed if anyone did
I mean Muller for whatever other
shortcomings people perceive that he has
I think he's tried to do a pretty good
job of keeping his business private I
have not seen a single piece of evidence
to suggest collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia
I know Schiff has I know some
journalists claim they have but I've
seen nothing and no one's interviewed
more witnesses than I have so I think
Muller is going to issue an exhaustive
report on what Russia did which should
unify America and then he's gonna
disappoint CNN and all my Democrat
friends by saying there's no evidence of
collusion that's what I think he's gonna
do and I think it'll happen before the
end of the year but I don't know that
mr. chairman do you think that acting
Attorney General Whitaker could expand
the investigation the other way into
looking at the FBI the early parts of
the investigation from inside the
administration well he could you know
chairman Goodlatte and I wrote a long
time ago we wrote attorney general
sessions and said we think reluctantly
but we think there ought to be a second
Special Counsel and I say that as
somebody who used to work for the
Department of Justice and wants to see
that institution restored to its
greatness but I think there ought to be
a second Special Counsel to look at the
origins of the Russia probe and the way
the FBI conducted itself I mean chairman
Goodlatte and I have been investigating
to the extent we can without a grand
jury or without compulsory process we've
been looking at what we can and I
deeply troubled he's not what the
Department and the bureau did and I
think another special counsel is
warranted and I thought that months ago
is it more likely that that happens with
the acting Attorney General what
occurred than not well my chances were
zero with sessions because he said no so
not to quote the movie Dumb and Dumber
but I guess it's one in a million I
guess it's better than it was with
suction so you saying you get a chance
all right I've got to say there's a
Chane seconds here your reaction to
losing the house I got surprised
historical headwinds retirements it's
it's really tough to win and off years
picked up seats in the Senate I'm sorry
for some of my friends that that aren't
coming back Mia love and Stevie Russell
and others but it's an unusual line of
work that we have chosen and the jury
has spoken and the jury is always right
and what about the president's saying
you know if you didn't stand with me too
bad today at the at the news conference
well we lost the scene in South Carolina
Katie Arrington stood with the president
a much more so than Mark Sanford and
regrettably he did not win so I think he
had tremendous success in the Senate
seats that he involved himself with the
house is just a different entity in it
and it's tough to win in off years the
historical headwinds the money that
poured in their retirements
I think Kevin and Paul knew that we were
in trouble even though they fought like
the dickens to prevent it I think it was
inevitable I didn't see his picking up
seats in the Senate so that was a plus
mr. chairman we appreciate your time as
always yes sir
thank you